in some ways there are some awkward
incompatibilities between the decimal
that we like to use and the binary which
is so efficient wonderful for computers
to use we've seen one example of this
already i think i mentioned in the in a
previous video that
0.1
or 0.10 10 cents in other words in
decimal your current bank balance is not
exactly representable as a binary number
you look at what it is in binary zero
point three zeros one one zero zero one
one zero it just isn't you know it keeps
on recurring just as one third in
decimal isn't exactly goes point three
three three v three forever
and binary sometimes don't mix
now here's going to be a classic example
let's just think this through without
even writing anything down if we've got
a four bit nibble we know that in hex it
goes from four zeros to one one one one
fifteen represented as f can't use that
full range this is binary coded decimal
not binary coded hexadecimal yeah we
have got to say that the moment that
representation even in one nibble gets
to one zero one zero that is ten
you can't leave it as one zero one zero
you've now got to have two nibbles
the left nibble with a one in it and the
right nibble wants to look like zero you
can't compress it into a single nibble
say one zero one zero and i'm sorry
folks you'll all have to learn hex
because otherwise you won't understand
your bank balance this is not going to
go down very well the challenge then is
if you're using a four bit nibble but
only for the decimal range naught to
nine you've somehow got to make in all
your bit twiddles
you've got to make it carry into another
nibble on the left at 10
and not at 16 which is what hexadecimal
would do for you so how does one sort of
bridge that gap
probably
the best way for me to
get into the hard bit about this is go
straight away for that magic number 10.
let's represent it in binary and then
say how do we convert it
into bcd
and realize that we need that second
nibble on the left what i'd like to do
here is to draw myself columns and i'm
going to restrict myself to things that
are at most two decimal digits let's
remind ourselves up here that we're
going to have
a tens nibble and a units nibble and
we'll initialize everything to zeros
but above here
just to keep things very simple we'll
use four bit binary representations
and i hope you will all agree
that one zero one zero
is ten in base ten and the reason for
that is that the binary in four bits
that's an eight that's a two so that's
ten this technique
which is called double dabble i don't
know how it was discovered it's
fiendishly clever but the idea is we'd
love to convert binary into bcd
by as far as possible using simple bit
shifts
all the time
and
doing the minimum of mucking about to
get it to carry early
so the double reflects the fact that
we're going to shift this bit pattern
across into here and we're going to
regard it as one huge great big 12-bit
register here
walloping great shift register all
joined together even though i've drawn
it out separately it's just going to
move from right across to the left i'm
going to move them across and remember
every time you shift the thing by one
place left you are basically doubling it
okay that's where the double comes from
but we found we have to intervene to
make it look right at the end and that
is where the dabble comes from if you
look up dabble as i did in chambers
dictionary it's one of the meanings is
to make a trivial alteration to okay to
make a small alteration to something
you're dabbling with it okay so that's
where double dabble comes
okay so it's basically doubling with a
little bit of dabbling
and the truth really hits you at 10. so
let's progressively shift this
by one bit left what's going to happen
first of all you shift over that one bit
you push it across into here because
this is a unified register for the
moment purists will say ah but when you
shift left like that you should fill in
with zeros on the right yes that is what
will actually happen inside the hardware
but i prefer not to pad with zeros on
the right side shaft because i want you
to see when i finished so we could call
this
shift number one let's do another one
that one moves into that position but
you're bringing over
another zero out of that part and that's
leaving you with one zero in there
now notice what's happened
on shift one here you had a one at the
right in that nibble by the time you
shifted it left one place it's in the
two's position so you've doubled it
let's do shift three
and a zero is left
so that is shift three now
this is where we can begin to see
trouble on the horizon we have got one
more shift left to do
and if you don't do anything about it
it's just going to end up with one zero
one zero in here i mean all right what's
happened here look is that was two
you doubled it but because you shifted
the one in and not a zero you've doubled
it and added one that now says five okay
so basically it's doubling but sometimes
if the bit you shift over is one and not
a zero it's double and add one but
essentially it's doubling
now
the trouble is coming on the horizon
because i can see that if i just push
that zero bit over here i'm going to end
up with 1 0 1 0 i know it is 10. fine
but that's hexadecimal
it's not representable as a digit from
naught to 9. so
what should you do then let it happen
anyway and then look at it and say oh my
golly he's gone to 10 he's gone to 11
he's gone to 15 even i better backtrack
and undo it and then redo it no
dive in early
and reason as follows
concentrate everybody okay
what we want here
is for this thing to come out
looking like
zero zero zero one
zero zero zero zero
let's say that's the desired result
because that
regarding these as bcd digits that's one
zero ten that's exactly what you want so
how do we make that happen how do we
make it carry over into this left hand
nibble here when it doesn't want to at
the moment
so the fiendish clever thing says take a
look at what you've currently got
because if what you've got is five or
more the act of doubling it is bound to
get you
into a number that needs to carry across
so if it is going to cause you trouble
at five or more
we wanted to carry a 10
it
innately would like to carry at 16 and
you don't want that what's the
difference sean between 10 and 16. six
six what's half of that three
all right so if we add three the fact
that we're then shifting it will double
that three contribution to six and we'll
make it carry
so the rule is on double dabble
if what you see in your nibble is five
or more
then add three
so here we go look
next stage now
because we've seen treble on the horizon
it's five so add three and three we
agree is one one now here you do have to
do as little addition with carries you
can't avoid it some carries will have to
take place one on one is zero carry one
one and one is zero carry one one on one
is zero carry one the act of adding
three will make it look not like zero
one zero one
you've added the three it now looks like
one zero zero zero magic but what
happens when you shift the final zero in
that one will shift left into the left
hand nibble
and you'll end up with not no no one
no no no not
and this thing is now empty so you know
you've come to the end of your
conversion it's so cool i love it dearly
you could argue though
the one problem with all this is that in
order to do your shifts quickly you've
got this in a sort of unified shift of
register full of bits
your nibbles
in the end end up looking correct but
you're going to have to dig them out of
the shift registers oh yeah it's clearly
that's a four yeah two isn't it magic of
course if you're using this seriously
you have to try and generate
these
bcd digits in a way where they don't
necessarily need digging out of a bigger
representation but on the other hand
you're using that behind the scenes i've
found for you
the uh
ultimate reference that i've taken this
example from and used the methodology
it's by a guy called chuck falconer it's
actually referred to in the wikipedia
articles on bcd and double dabble so
we've pulled that over it's freely
available you can go and dive in there
to your heart's content because he
covers about how to make them appear in
a
much more usable way and what he also
says is that when you start looking at
this you realize you are actually doing
the division by 10 and remainders thing
that we discussed but you're doing it in
a pretty efficient way and only
occasionally needing that little
addition of three so
that's i'm not saying there aren't other
ways there's seems to be endless
variants on this there's
signed b c d there's packed b c d
there's all sorts but if you just want
to understand the fundamentals
i would say
go through the 42 example then go to
chuck falconer's memo and he does 255
as decimal
and boy that needs spotting problems in
about three sets of nibbles not two you
have to spot one in the middle thing
happening and so on you've mentioned two
five five so this goes up to hundreds
thousands yes yes you just add more you
add more bcd digits on the left to cope
but you give yourself a bigger problem
when
examining
each of these digits to see if they're
about to go beyond 10 when they're
doubled by shifting left one more time
you give yourself a bigger and bigger
inspection task there's no question
so
uh like i say the the chuck folk and a
memo from which this is derived we'll
put a link out to it it is freely
available
it doesn't explain how the people who
invented this actually
discovered it and worked out that it
really does work it seems almost like
magic when you do it and
every so often i pull out another number
i think i bet it won't work for this but
it does it's quite incredible
so there we are then i think we've
fairly well summarized now what the
situation is that for great big
engineering scientific calculations even
for finding new prime numbers as huge
integers you really do need proper
binary to speed things up
but for some sorts of trivial
calculations
you might even want to do it in bcd all
the time
but even if you are basically binary and
want to print out your answers you still
have to convert from binary through to
bcd and that is always a a worry for the
people who write the i o routines shall
we say for c and so on is is this
going to be efficient what we're saying
is
at the computing end of things you
should be able to prepare that bcd digit
stream as quickly as possible
to finish off with then life the
universe and everything
would this work for converting 42
yes it will
now admittedly
here's one i did earlier
so